on the afternoon of his inauguration
president biden reversed the america
first policy of his predecessor
signing an executive order starting the
process of rejoining the paris climate
deal
the u.s opted back into the world health
organization
and the un human rights council the new
u.s president
fulfilling his campaign promise to
re-engage with the world
and bind his country again to its
traditional allies
with its adversaries though relations
have deteriorated
in an interview president biden called
the russian leader vladimir putin a
killer
and amid growing tensions for a time
over a hundred and fifty thousand
russian troops
were massed on the border with ukraine
i'm also hearing deep concern
about some of the actions your
government is taking
public disagreement with china was on
open display
during a high-level meeting in anchorage
alaska in a most unusual exchange the
top
chinese and u.s foreign policy officials
arguing over human rights
trade and cyber attacks but as the biden
administration was perhaps hoping
it's not stopped renewed engagement on
some issues
here the u.s climate envoy john kerry
talking with china's vice premier han
zhung
just before the two countries released a
joint statement
on protecting the planet some of the
us's allies will tell you privately
that they believe president biden has
been just a little bit too slow and
cautious
on two of the world's most pressing
issues
on iran although the administration had
made it clear it wanted to rejoin the
nuclear deal
it didn't seem in any great hurry its
delay may have complicated negotiations
now back
underway in vienna on afghanistan it was
only two weeks ago that president biden
signaled he'd pull us
troops from the country but the plan to
get the taliban around a table to
negotiate with the afghan government
now looks very shaky a former obama
administration official who worked with
many of those now running u.s foreign
policy
says one place is more important than
any other
in their decision making biden knows
that
in the congress he's got a slim majority
in both houses
he's got to work hard to retain those
and that is why even when it comes to
foreign policy
the domestic agenda trumps and he's
looking
at you know all of these issues whether
it's afghanistan whether it's the
challenge in central america with uh
migration how these are going to impact
in
key congressional districts and key
states so
unfortunately uh all politics
is local including foreign policy
in other words in determining his
international agenda
president biden is still putting the
immediate political calculations in
america
first james bay's al jazeera of the
united nations